[Music]
my sheets were cold tonight had leave
them for a dying fire burn No Time for
Dreams
lovely Soul you've found to see silent
empty house I cannot breathe you said
too many
[Music]
night can I keep spinning to turn turn
time can I just fall back in
walk so when you ask I always say you
the S going to try to live inside a
dream
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
la
[Music]
looking up the
dusty listening there wasn't time to Cas
Fe kicked out from under
me then I your eyes face and I keep them
looking for a fure time to help me when
I try to fly
by can I keep spinning to your turn turn
turn can I just fall back in your
in when you ask always sing you a song
about his girl trying to live inside a
dream
[Music]
oh